my name for the public sphere is j
smooth I'm the composer arranger and
conductor of New York's longest-running
hip hop radio show the Underground
Railroad also a blogger at hip hop music
com and a video blogger at ill doctrine
calm
onto radio because there was a sense of
intimacy they're just sitting at home
listening to someone's voice that I felt
like was unique compared to television
any other stuff that was out there and I
think what we have now with blogging and
especially video blogging it sort of
recreate that intimacy in a different
way you know having my face inside the
box there at home it's sort of as a bit
of the mystique of television but it's a
more intimate personal thing and I feel
like radio I don't think video is going
to go extinct but certainly the role of
radio plays in our lives has diminished
somewhat you know with all the resources
we have online and I saw pretty early on
you know I've been working in the
nonprofit media world so that false
sense of security that mainstream media
people had I never had that I always had
a sense of this opportunity this
opportunity that I have to propagate my
voice it could disappear at any moment
because when you're at a small nonprofit
station you're always going through lots
of turbulence and barely surviving so I
saw I'm pretty earlier on it the
internet was a place where I could plant
my own flag and have sort of an
autonomous voice like have have an
outlet for my voice that I owned and
controlled and would always be there and
I think we've seen people who work in
mainstream media sort of shift over to
seeing the internet that way the way
that I did in the late 90s I think we
see more and more people recognizing
that as the music industry as a whole
and you know various forms of old media
start falling apart and becoming a lot
less viable people are seeing that the
internet is a place where on a smaller
scale you know you can plant your own
flag and make sure your voice is out
there and build a more direct connection
with your audience and you could before
so I've been drawn to the internet for a
long time because of that and I think
web video is the place where you can do
that most effectively now
obviously internet media is much more of
a two-way experience I mean on the radio
you can take phone calls and get a
little bit of feedback when you do print
media I used to also work for the source
and various magazines like that you were
to write your review and it would go out
there and they ether and you never
really get a sense of what the response
was but when with anything you do online
you have this precise measurement of
exactly how many people viewed it you
see dozens or hundreds of responses if
you're lucky enough to get viewed that
much you know you get a very detailed
view of what the public's response to it
is and you're able to converse with them
and you sort of build a conversation out
of it that to me I mean to me once I put
my initial piece of conversation out
there and the public adds on to it that
to me is an integral part of the piece
like I feel like I'm writing the first
chapter of something and in the comments
that come underneath it is a part of the
work that we create collaboratively so I
feel like there's much more of a
connection with your audience than you
were ever able to have certainly in
radio or in print media and I think a
lot of old media people are very
intimidated by that you see when
old-school journalists start blogs and
things like that they seem to be
horrified and by having these comments
right underneath or even just when
newspaper sites are set up so that
readers are able to comment underneath
reporters are aghast at having this sort
of feedback right underneath and they
have a lot of difficulty coping with
that which i think is interesting
because you hear a lot about how new
media doesn't have the checks and
balances through an editorial process
that keeps you on point but I think
there's a similar set of checks and
balances and new media that comes after
you put your work out there because
you're accountable to the public and
because they're crowd sourcing and it's
not just each individual anyway that you
were slipping you're going to get caught
slipping once you put it out there if
you have a substantial audience so I
think there's a connection with the
audience that's fairly different than
what you were ever able to have an old
media and I think it helps you approach
your expression in new ways that you
wouldn't have done before
think we're looking out at a new
frontier right now as far as how anyone
who's trying to express themselves
creatively or just deal in the realm of
ideas as a journalist or a writer how
are you going to find a way to survive
as an artist or a creative person I
think we're all trying to figure that
out I think the Internet is going to
provide ways for you to do that on a
smaller scale and you know what a lot of
us are hoping is that the era of people
seeing hip hop as a get-rich-quick
scheme is going to fall by the wayside
and people who really have a deep
commitment to creating art that connects
with people are going to be able to do
that more than ever on a smaller scale
Amanda you have I think it's the seth
godin theory as long as you have 2,000
loyal fans that's enough for you to
subsist as a creative person or anyone
with the public voice and I'm hoping
that bit by bit hip hop is going to
recognize that that's the way you can
sustain yourself and I think you know a
lot of a lot of things that the younger
generation is doing that we as older
hiphopheads look down upon I see signs
of hope in someone like soldier boy who
musically aesthetically we hate if you
look at the model that he's established
for how to direct how to connect leader
echt with your audience completely out
of the mainstream and build a lasting
relationship he's far past being a
one-hit wonder now and he's done it
without any of the pretensions that
major label rappers were offering to the
public that he doesn't have any of that
sort of gangster mythology he's not
pretending to be anything else but a
regular kid who's connecting with
regular kids out there through YouTube
and you know he's built a franchise that
doesn't show any signs of slowing down
much as we may not like the music and I
feel like that's a model that a lot of
us could look towards you know for how
to create art that you know I think
there's no reason that this generations
public enemy can't follow that soldier
boy model and connect with people and
recreate that success so I'm hoping that
uh
people who represent hip hop in all the
various little sub cultures and
communities around the world where
hip-hop is blossom and bloom I hope we
can each see I hope we can all see how
new media gives us a chance to sustain
ourselves and get our stuff out there
I think any artists responsibility is
first and foremost to create good art
and I think hip-hop I'm certainly not
the first to say this probably not the
first to say this on big think but
hip-hop has always been held to
standards that I thought were
unrealistic and unfair and standards
that no other modern pop music form has
been held to as far as the our lyrical
content and how much we deliver a
substantive message or whether we craft
our music into a comprehensive handbook
for how to live your life I me I don't
think anyone has ever looked at blues or
jazz or country or any other form no one
has ever looked at John Coltrane and
said he's failing as an artist because
he didn't provide a detailed blueprint
for political change in our country or a
detailed blueprint for how to raise your
children because people recognize that
the value of John Coltrane's music comes
in its musical expressiveness but with
hip-hop a lot of people don't recognize
hip hop's musical value so they latch on
to what's easier for them to understand
which is a lyrical content and judges
strictly on that basis so I think
hip-hop gets a raw deal in a lot of ways
especially because right when hip-hop
was beginning to be discovered by the
mainstream is right towards the end of
what people call a conscious aryl groups
like Public Enemy who raised hopes very
high for having this generation fill the
void that had been left behind when the
civil rights movement ended the black
power era had ended due to COINTELPRO
and self implosion and whatever else
went on I mean I think people were
hoping for some kind of voice to rise up
and when you had Public Enemy and all
the other groups around him speaking so
compellingly I think people got their
hopes so high that they get really
unrealistic expectations for how much
these young musicians could really
deliver as far as offering substantive
social and political leadership you know
and I think I mean I working working in
sort of a left-wing progressive circle
of nonprofit media has always been a
struggle for me to get people to
recognize that hip-hop should be
recognized for its musical value first
and foremost and if we're making
music than we did our jobs and if we're
expressing something that's explicitly
political or positive that's great but
that's icing on the cake if you don't
have the foundation a great music
underneath that you know it doesn't
matter if it was all about the message
and all of the message Cornel West would
be the best rapper in the world which
I'm sure he would agree he is not
the most obvious assumptions people make
about how the media's representation a
young black men would affect our public
consciousness both as young black men as
everyone else and for everyone else
looking at young black man I think the
obvious assumptions people make about
how that now representation affects
people is true I mean that gives young
black men a very narrow sense of what
their opportunities are I mean I think
you can see that all the time anyone who
works with kids you know you see what
they aspire to be obviously we hope
that's expanding now or certain other
recent developments I do think that the
rise of hip-hop is also and the the
standard the example that athletes have
set more recently I think it's expanded
our concept of what we can do because
there's been a phenomenon of
entrepreneurship both in this generation
of athletes and in this generation of
hip hoppers that has also shown the kids
that you know you don't need to be just
an artist who's out there on stage and
getting exploited you can also be on top
of the business end and have other
franchises and enterprises and build
something beyond that and I think you
know a lot of people like someone like
Diddy is sort of built a reputation as
an entrepreneur more than as an artist
and I think that's one of the good
things that's happened as we've seen
this generation of athletes and hip
hoppers develop is even within that
narrow window that they give to us
they've forced in a wider palette for
kids to see and latch onto but I still
think you know a lot of people in
America and around the world their
impression of what a black man is it can
be comes from 50 cent and I think 50
cent is more complex than a lot of
people give him credit for but
nonetheless see you know he's certainly
on his records if not in his interviews
he represents a very narrow concept of
hyper-masculinity and so on you know
that is reductive and I mean I think I
mean I've
I don't know I mean I think socially
we've been connecting more and more and
hip-hop has been a part of that so and
we have so much more exposure to each
other through the internet and other
forms of media that I don't I don't
think anyone is as a reliant on
television and movies to form their
entire impression of other cultures as
they used to be so I hope that you know
the reductive impact the mass media has
and how they portray us is going to be
lessened more and more because I think
it's inevitable that there's going to be
a reductive representation because in
order to in order for you to take a
culture and change it into a product you
have to simplify it down into something
that can be branded and described in
five words or less like it there's never
going to be a complete representation of
who any of us are as human beings where
we're being turned into a media
commodity so I my biggest hope I think
is that will continue connecting with
each other in smaller ways outside of
those mass media windows and sort of get
more of a sense of how much we all have
in common despite those differences on
the surface
I think hip-hop has always had a problem
with letting itself be criticized and I
think that notion that your year either
supposed to support me or say something
positive or just keep quiet and keep it
to yourself I mean I that belief has
been around and hip-hop pretty much as
long as if I've has been around and
that's why the Internet has become so
scary for hip-hop artists as well
because now you have bloggers and people
who are independent of the media machine
who you know who are expressing their
views much more frankly in a much more
detail than you had before and rappers
and labels are not able to control those
independent voices and you have you know
much harsher critiques than you had
before and I think that's been a big
adjustment for the hip-hop world is that
new level of accountability that the
internet brings and I think the concept
of a player hater is one and one that
people still try to enforce I see that
you know any you see that all the time
artists will describe any sort of
critique as hating you know I always say
that the true definition of a hater is
someone who tries to dismiss any
criticism as hating yeah I mean I think
we need to I think and this is a
phenomenon that goes beyond hip-hop
there's always a sense that um any sort
of minority expression you know such as
let's say black filmmakers for example
there's always been a sense for many
people in the black community that we
need to always speak positively of the
work even if it's mediocre are not
really up to snuff because we need to
support these artists you know and we
need to support this because it's not
enough of it out there and I think that
principle has been in effect for hip-hop
as well but I think hip-hop is
established enough now that we can sort
of shift and support our artists by
setting high standards for them and you
know not pretend that everyone's turds
are made of gold i mean i think if we
really love and respect our artists you
know we can check them and hold them to
a high standard and critique them
harshly because we respect them enough
and admire their work enough that we
believe they can meet our high standards
i think i think that's the ultimate show
of respect is to criticize someone
frankly and you know i think we as fans
and commentators and artists should all
kind of adjust to that recognize the hip
hop has grown up from we could take
has always been around I mean obviously
a predates hip-hop sort of approaching
your artistic expression in a
competitive ways been around you know
specifically in the black community for
ages and ages with the dozens and with
the sort of competitive storytelling the
zora neale hurston documented and mules
and men you know you can see lots of
precursors in the world of music George
Clinton calling out cool in the gang and
Earth Wind and Fire you know James Brown
calling out the average white band or
even you know the Beatles and the stones
you know a lot lots of people are
competitive and hip-hop itself grew in
the 70s out of a scene in the South
Bronx it was dominated by gangs like the
savage skulls and the Black Spades you
know who had very real beef going on and
hip-hop blossomed as sort of an outlet
for them to either have an oasis from
that beef when they went to Kool Herc
sparty or as people like BAM Afrika
Bambaataa continued to develop it they
specifically shaped it into an
alternative outlet for that beef and
competition where you know starting even
back in the early 60s before people were
calling anything hip-hop you know you
had those gangs and the Bronx stepping
to each other was sort of ritualized
dance moves like the sort of top rocking
and up rocking that was the initial
first version of breakdancing or
b-boying you know you saw that going
back to the early 60s according to heads
they were there and you know hip-hop has
always been a way to sort of take that
competitive spirit and pride on your
block and competitiveness with the next
block hip-hop has always been an outlet
for that sort of energy but that's
always been a thread but I think as
hip-hop became contrived from the early
90s on into this forum where we need to
live out this street life mythology
things got blurred to a point where
people thought they had to act out that
beef you know people got caught up in
the beef and forgot that they were just
doing a competitive art form and felt
like they had to live it out another
form so the beef has become the concept
of beef has become something that's more
toxic and more perilous than it was for
most of hip-hop's history and I you know
I think obviously we had some major
tragedies in hip hop that no one knows
in detail what happened with the deaths
of Biggie in pocket but certainly you
know there was beef that led up to that
ultimate ending and I think you know
people have sorted backed away from
taking things that far and I think beef
nowadays it's not even the thing is
wrong with beef nowadays isn't even if
there's the threat of it becoming
something at least a real violence has
just become so sort of inane and insipid
because the beef is not even about
making songs anymore like beef plays out
in other multimedia forms where I make a
youtube video about you then you make a
youtube video about me where you find my
grade school teacher and interview her
about how I used to wet the bed and then
you go and find my ex-girlfriend and you
know talk about how I was impotent and
there's this there's so much other TMZ
style drama that goes on instead of
having to beef inspire us to make great
music which was what always went on even
with Biggie and POC you know the beefs
that turned ugly there was always at the
core we were trying to represent and
show that we were the best musician but
now it's sort of we're the best at
creating tabloid gossip is what the beef
is based on as I think you know hip-hop
beef has become tiresome in that sense
the greatest challenge to our innovation
and ingenuity has been the decreased
ability to work with sample-based
production actually um I mean I think
that's the greatest explosion of
artistic innovation to me was when
sampling technology was available but
the sampling laws were not yet in place
we had free rein to create what Prince
Paul created for De La Soul with the
bomb squad created for Public Enemy what
the Dust Brothers created on the Beastie
Boys second album and I think the
sampling laws that came in a couple of
years after that were very stifling and
brought things in another direction
where you know people are still creative
in various ways and people who have a
budget to be able to work with samples
like Kanye are just blaze can continue
doing that but a lot of other people
have to find alternative ways and I
think that sort of tug-of-war between
artistic expression and protectors of
intellectual property is something we're
seeing you know in many different places
in media not just in hip-hop but that's
been one of the most dramatic places
where to me the value of the art that
was created by us having free rein to
create whatever pastiche a montage we
wanted to create I mean it seemed it
always seemed clear to me that we were
creating something new and valuable and
adhering to the same creative process
that everyone has throughout the history
of music just the technology allows us
to do it in a different way by
manipulating the actual recordings
instead of working with those influences
in different ways I mean you can go back
to go all throughout the history of
music back to the first in western music
the first polyphonic music was based on
taking a Gregorian chant in the lower
register and then singing a new
Gregorian chant senior new melody on top
of that in a higher register so that's
you're basically you're taking a song
and then adding something new on top of
it that's the same creative process as
if I and you can see other parallels
throughout music history the only
difference is that in the mid 90s we had
samplers that let us actually manipulate
the recordings and do it that way
instead of other ways you know you can
look at jazz standards you can look at
what led zeppelin did with blues tracks
you know this
that all throughout music but people get
caught up in the fact that we're using
the actual recordings and see it as lazy
but if you've ever tried to make a beat
as hot as with the bomb squad made or
trying to make a beat like Just Blaze
made or even the beats that we see is
really simplistic like the beats that
did he made if you try to make a beat to
sounded that good you'd find it's much
harder than you think it is and I think
the amount of creativity and innovation
that goes into sample-based if park is
very underrated
I think the skip gates scandal was a
great example of how far we are from
being post-racial obviously and I don't
think being post-racial is a worthy
ideal you know I think being colorblind
or being post-racial to me that's kind
of like when people talk about secondary
virginity is something is something that
could never exist and it wouldn't be
worth having if you were able to get it
I mean III think we should be fully
comfortable with seeing someone who's
ever different ethnicity and recognizing
that they are the problem comes when we
make a rational assumptions after we
noticed that he rose I don't want I
don't think any I don't think anyone
wants I like if you forget race and look
at gender I don't think most women want
people to look at them and not notice
whether they're a man or a woman it's
just do you make assumptions about who
they are and what they're capable of
after you notice there a woman you know
I think our our culture and ethnicity
you know for most of us is a big part of
who we are that we take pride in and I
think you know I hope that we're able to
become more racial rather than becoming
post-racial you know and be able to
recognize you know our differences in a
rational way and relish them and
appreciate them and be able to talk
about them frankly instead of hoping to
never notice our differences or discuss
them away I mean to me that's being
afraid of something that's not being
comfortable with it but i think the Skip
gate scandal was certainly a reminder
that there's a lot of work to do both in
our perceptions and in how our
institutions function and I think that
aspect is what unfortunately was lost
and how to gate scandal played out you
know there's been in the way that Obama
has addressed race which I think he's
addressed it extremely well the one flaw
that I felt like was there is there's
been so much of an emphasis on
conversation and on each of us
acknowledging and honoring the other
person's feelings and perspectives and
recognizing where those feelings come
from that we've lost track of how racism
and injustice as an injustice and
inequity also matter
best in ways beyond personal feeling and
personal expression and thoughts there's
also institutional inequity
institutional racism and systemic
inequity and you know those are things
that can't be fixed by conversation and
sharing each other's thoughts and
understanding and I think what you saw
in the Skip gate scandal um skip gates
he made errors in the way that he spoke
Obama made an error in a way that he
spoke but that officer Crowley he didn't
make an error in how he spoke him he
abused his power to arrest somebody and
he was backed up by the institution that
he represents that you know that's a
very widespread problem of police
abusing their power that is not
something you can fix by having the
conversation over a beer there needs to
be changes in how we trained police
officers I need to be changes in the
policies that we enforce you know so
that yeah I mean the people spoke about
officer Crowley as if it was a rogue or
a bad apple but it seems clear to me
that he wasn't a rogue he was he was
someone who provided training on these
issues and was trained in such a way
that he thought it was okay for him to
arrest somebody because he didn't like
their attitude inside their own home and
you saw his institution back him up
after he did that so I think he wasn't
being a bad apple he was doing what he
was trained to do and we need to enact
change on an institutional level to stop
that from happening again because it
happens to thousands of people who don't
have the connections officer gates has
and the consequences are not going to be
a beer with the president you know it's
going to when it escalates is going to
escalate to a Taser or a night stick or
something worse than that and I think
that's something I wish had been focused
on more I mean it's great for us to
encourage conversation but I wish that
President Obama had also taken some time
to note that there are bigger things
than conversation that need to happen
with this issue
I think the skip gates scandal you know
was a great example of how far we are
from being post-racial obviously and I
don't think being post-racial is a
worthy ideal you know I think being
colorblind or being post-racial to me
that's kind of like when people talk
about secondary virginity is something
is something that could never exist and
it wouldn't be worth having if you were
able to get it I mean III think we
should be fully comfortable with seeing
someone who's ever different ethnicity
and recognizing that they are the
problem comes when we make a rational
assumptions after we noticed that he
rose I don't want I don't think any I
don't think anyone wants I like if you
forget race and look at gender I don't
think most women want people will look
at them and not notice whether they're a
man or a woman it's just do you make
assumptions about who they are and what
they're capable of after you notice
there a woman you know I think our our
culture and ethnicity you know for most
of us is a big part of who we are that
we take pride in and I think you know I
hope that we're able to become more
racial rather than becoming post-racial
you know and be able to recognize you
know our differences in a rational way
and relish them and appreciate them and
be able to talk about them frankly
instead of hoping to never notice our
differences or discuss them away I mean
to me that's being afraid of something
that's not being comfortable with it but
i think the Skip gate scandal was
certainly a reminder that there's a lot
of work to do both in our perceptions
and in how our institutions function and
I think that aspect is what
unfortunately was lost and how to gate
scandal played out you know there's been
in the way that Obama has addressed race
which I think he's addressed it
extremely well the one flaw that I felt
like was there is there's been so much
of an emphasis on conversation and on
each of us acknowledging and honoring
the other person's feelings and
perspectives and recognizing where those
feelings come from that we've lost track
of how racism and injustice as an
injustice and inequity also matt
fast in ways beyond personal feeling and
personal expression and thoughts there's
also institutional inequity
institutional racism and systemic
inequity and you know those are things
that can't be fixed by conversation and
sharing each other's thoughts and
understanding and I think what you saw
in the Skip gate scandal um skip gates
he made errors in the way that he spoke
Obama made an error in a way that he
spoke but that officer Crowley he didn't
make an error in how he spoke him he
abused his power to arrest somebody and
he was backed up by the institution that
he represents that you know that's a
very widespread problem of police
abusing their power that is not
something you can fix by having the
conversation over a beer there needs to
be changes in how we trained police
officers I need to be changes in the
policies that we enforce you know so
that yeah I mean the people spoke about
officer Crowley as if it was a rogue or
a bad apple but it seems clear to me
that he wasn't a rogue he was he was
someone who provided training on these
issues and was trained in such a way
that he thought it was okay for him to
arrest somebody because he didn't like
their attitude inside their own home and
you saw his institution back him up
after he did that so I think he wasn't
being a bad apple he was doing what he
was trained to do and we need to enact
change on an institutional level to stop
that from happening again because it
happens to thousands of people who don't
have the connections officer gates has
and the consequences are not going to be
a beer with the president you know it's
going to when it escalates is going to
escalate to a Taser or a night stick or
something worse than that and I think
that's something I wish had been focused
on more I mean it's great for us to
encourage conversation but I wish that
President Obama had also taken some time
to note that there are bigger things
than conversation that need to happen
with this issue